hey what's up guys my name is a turn-on
welcome to episode 30 the final episode
of network share programming so today
we're going to basically implement one
more thing that you guys wanted to
implement and that was the client being
able to like bring up a dialog box which
says who's online I'm going to be doing
that today and and also we'll just clean
up the server kind of and maybe add a
few things like help like like a help
command which lists all the available
commands whatever just just some kind of
admin clean up stuff again we'll fix a
few bugs as well that we have here in
there so first of all though we're just
gonna focus on doing the feature that
you guys want to see and that is a bit
of a client kind of list right a list of
online users now to do this right
there's a lot of ways we could do this
the way that I've chosen to do this
right is in order to show you guys it's
just to make it a lot easier if you guys
to basically see what is going on and
what I mean if I log in here there's no
server actually running but whatever if
I log in here what I want to do is kind
of like a like a file like it on Mac
will be up here like a like I use like
am what he thought like one of those um
like I guess a menu bar right there
called menu bars and you can go like
file and then options or file extensions
green and it'll be a constantly updating
list of who's online okay simple as that
and you can close it you can open it
again whatever now one thing I want to
fix though before we do that and it's
going to be important here is you can
see what where whenever we kind of
resize this window it kind of works when
we go outward you can see but when we go
in you can see that the same thing kind
of just goes away okay and that's a bit
of a bug with the with the grid back
layout that we kind of employed here so
let's go ahead and fix that okay and we
kind of easy to fix as well so don't
worry about that now in order to fix
that what we're gonna do is it's first
of all open our client window of course
because that contains everything
everything that we need to fix that and
then all obviously over here is all of
our stuff right now let's go ahead and
play around with this first of all call
them weights and right away its we
should probably set up with all this to
zero okay
because the reason is we don't want that
to be overriding what we said in
individually here so basically what
column weights and row weights does is
it sets
I guess the weighting of each component
okay but it automatically sets each
component in a particular rolling column
so a great a a grid bag layout works in
the way of having a bit of like
basically just a grid and then you have
components in cells in that grid right
so obviously because it's a grid it has
a column and it has columns and rows and
and the way that it works is that each
each component in a PC in a particular
cell has a weight okay and this kind of
sets the default inant overrides
everything we don't want that so we want
to basically set us all to zero zeros
are actually the default so we can just
get rid of this okay and then what we
can do is is specify the weight of
everything individually okay so for
example we've got this this text area
over here yeah and what what we could do
with that is set the width the the
weight sorry
individually right so for example
Anderson a scroll thing by the way which
is important tonight so scroll
constraints dot weight X okay we'll set
that equal to one and we'll do the same
for the white wine okay and I'll explain
what on earth this weight stuff is so
basically if you hover your mouse over
it you get a nice explanation and
specify how to distribute extra
horizontal space okay so when we resize
a component well actually not know
that's a bad way of saying it whenever
we resize the window the space of course
where our components it's that gets
bigger right because the window is
getting bigger now this weight tells
tells basically this is the specified
component here which is scroll
constraints it tells that component how
to resize along with the window if we
set this to zero it will not resize it
will always stay the same the same size
because what we'll actually do is just
insert whitespace into the into the
areas in between right if we set this
equal to one right then the component
will actually get larger so this text
area will actually grow when we resize
that's good that's exactly what we want
it to do however with something like
the button for example so if we scroll
down here the button send we don't want
that to actually resize do we we kind of
we don't want the button to get bigger
or anything we want the button to stay
the same the same size so we could just
simply go ahead and set and set button
send don't wait X equal to zero and same
with Y okay and that would just make
sure that it does not resize and then
we'll also go up here into our our text
message here and we'll do a similar
thing here except what we'll do is we'll
a basically GBC text message dot will
set the the x width equal to one and we
won't touch the Y at all okay and now
the reason is we wanted to resize
horizontally yeah but we don't want to
let's actually explicitly state the Y
you don't have to because the default is
actually zero but I'm just I'm writing
all this here just for you people to see
exactly what it is right but the default
is zero so this stuff is not really
necessary but again no harm keeping it
keeping it in there of course now wait X
of course if that's set to one that'll
basically allow us to resize things
horizontally so in other words what will
happen is the the frame the actual
component here so this is the text
message that's the text field it will
resize horizontally but it will not
resolve at eclis so in other words the
width will change based on the window
but the height will never change the
height is static the height is the same
okay brilliant okay so let's just tell
this out really quickly see if this
works
so yawn oops localhost don't want this
init and lump of any of this matters
right now but okay so fertile it looks
the same which is good now if we resize
it you can see that this sends stuff it
stays the same so we can resize it to
however small large we want you can see
that this this text thing it it doesn't
move if we resize vertically it stays
exactly the same
but horizontally it will get smaller and
larger and similar thing with the send
button the send button will never change
okay now if we were to do something like
set the send button
let's go down here just to demonstrate
the the white Y for example to one that
would mean it would resize on the y axis
vertically so the button would actually
change size and this is gonna be
probably pretty
here but if we drag this up you can see
that you can actually see the difference
right there it's really hard to show you
guys but that's you you can kind of tell
all of the white space over here so we
want to we want to keep it okay at zero
if you take it up to two probably even
worse here okay so you can see if we
take it up to two we have this nice
little problem here where it just you
can see the button kind of even changes
changes appearance here so basically we
just want to keep that at zero because
we never want the button to actually
change okay
simple as that now let's get on with it
okay it's been a while
oh yeah discussing all this grid back
stuff but um what we want to do now is
kind of actually change how our grid
back system works and the reason is we
want to insert a menu okay now let's
probably look better and work better on
Windows but we'll do it anyway okay so
what we want to do is we'll come up here
okay and then we go there's column
widths and column and row Heights okay
and those things right those things have
a few values they I'm just gonna play
around with them a bit okay so I'll
change this to 25 that'll make the the
first row a bit a bit well I guess less
tall because that's the height will
change this okay this has to add up to
550 don't don't forget otherwise we'll
get we'll get glitches and stuff we'll
change this to four out five so we've
taken away ten from here and we've added
into here we're just making the texture
a bit larger and that Y space at the
beginning a bit smaller with the column
width I think we'll just leave them as
they are they look pretty good to me I
get a fine great now that's pretty much
it okay now if we go to let's
right-click on this we'll come over here
into our navigator we will right click
on our let's see our client window yeah
and we'll um we'll go open with window
bill to edit if it's not already open in
that okay and then up just that just
allowed to click the design tab here and
I'll just drag this up so you guys can
see but basically there's a design tab
click on it and you'll be able to see
your window in the window builder thing
alright great so let's just uh drag this
up hope
you guys can see this well but
essentially what we want to do first of
all is go back to source real quick
let's go ahead and find the text area we
want to shift that down so grid Y will
change to one okay and I think
everything else will stay at now okay
I think everything else will stay the
same probably yeah okay let's just see
what that looks like let's go back to
design all right great yeah so that's
kind of worked you can see that we've
got this white space at the top now so
what I'll do is I'll select a under
under menu there's a menu a little tab
here under that I will select a J menu
and I'll pop it right over here it says
even says menu bar would be placed here
brilliant let's place it there and then
we can add items so if you come over
here into AJ menu you can add one so
I'll make one and I'll call it like file
for example you guys can call this
whatever you want I did not mean to let
scroll down here I did not mean to to
put that in all caps but um and then we
can have something like you know online
uses and then just for good measure I'll
probably put one to close the
application as well so where's our arm
put one here just called exit just to
make it look a bit more populated
populated ok great now if we launch this
okay log in real quick you can see over
here it looks ridiculous on Mac because
it's supposed to be up here but we've
got this little box here now this is
become a bit of a problem we can see
it's behind it and that's all right no
we need to do to fix that is change the
width here or the height rather to just
be one okay there's a few different ways
you could do this actually if we leave
this on - because I think it's probably
gonna look better if we do that'll
basically take up two cells of course
and what we could do here is we could
just simply actually put this back to
back to zero because the menu bar kind
of lives in a wall of its own so if we
launch that and we test that out what
we're gonna get is isn't is basically
perfection here okay so you've got file
on one users and file exit let's make
this stuff work now
or to make that stuff work we're gonna
go into design we're gonna basically
right click here on online users and
we're gonna go to add event handler
action action performed all right now
we've done that we've got this little
box here and we can actually do
something like for example sure a
message okay I'll show something
anything we want so in order to do that
first of all I'm actually gonna make a
new class so when under our channel chat
folder here I'll go right click new and
then other and then I'll select AJ frame
here it's under window build a swing
design enjoy frame hit next
I'll call it online users okay and I'll
hit finish great now we're gonna do a
few things here I'm gonna remove this
entire main method okay now the only
thing that interests us is is set
visible but we don't actually need to
have it here at all so I'll just remove
everything okay and then all this stuff
will remove it as well okay set bounds
I'm probably gonna play around with that
just because we don't want it to be that
a specific size I'll set the size to
something along the lines of narrative
and we'll set size ourselves to maybe
about 200 by about maybe 350 320 maybe
alright that's pretty good okay one
thing we'll do actually okay I'll just
switch over to design so you guys can
see it a bit better this is what this is
what we look like right now alright so
if we if we actually had Java seven we'd
be able to change the type of this to be
a what's called a utility box it's like
a utility window but some that was added
in Java 7 and we're actually running
Java 6 here so I'm not gonna I'm not
going to deal with that but what you
would be able to do if you were running
um just fix this up here if you were
running Java 7 is you'd be able to do
something on the lines of set type and
then type dot utility and that would
actually make it look very very
different but we can't do that right
here so the best we can do is just keep
it as a normal window okay unfortunately
I do recommend you guys do that though
because it looks a little nicer okay
let's add a default serial version ID
and it's top of that now we want to have
a few methods here okay we want to have
a public void actually yeah okay a
public would update along with a string
array of users so in other words this is
what's going to populate our list that
we're about to put in and that is pretty
much it for now okay
if we switch back over to the to design
you'll be able to okay so first of all
let's actually just drag in under where
are we
let's scroll up under containers I'm
sorry under layouts we'll find a grid
bag layout here and we'll just pop it up
pop it in onto this window here and I'm
the other thing we'll do on the
components is we will find AJ lists and
we'll just pop it in okay into the most
top left grid again that'll pop up into
the entire thing here which is brilliant
okay so now we've got a list a J list
okay now you should actually add a
generic type to it that might have been
added in a Java 7
looks like it was Wow okay that's
alright so over here and users right
first of all with this J list we should
grab this and we should put it up here
into private J list I already done it
okay does matter I'll just paste it in
okay great okay so list and then over
here in users will simply go ahead and
say list dot dot set data or something
along those lines what was it set list
daughter I think yeah okay uses and of
course because of this well this is
still work because it's an object but we
can't unfortunately eat your nurse with
it but that's alright that works fine
okay and that'll basically just set our
list of users to be down okay it's very
very simple this class now you might
have noticed we don't have any kind of
set visible things and we don't need to
that's the beauty of this thing one
thing we do want to do is under set
default close operation let's just set
j4e exit on close make sure you change
that otherwise when you close this
online users window you entire client
will close so set this equal to dispose
on close and you'll be great it'll just
get rid of the window when you close it
ctrl shift or command shift I will just
get rid of those unused impulse and
clean it clean everything up for you now
in client window I'm gonna make a
private online users I'll call it users
okay over here when we start this I'll
set users equal to online users okay
I'll make a new instance of it sorry new
online users and then over here in I'll
actually have another oh yes
we've added a I'm sorry I have such over
the design in the menu bar we added an
action performed here so we'll set users
dot visible sorry users are set visible
to true okay great and that'll actually
show that window
so now let's test this out let's go
ahead and we actually haven't updated it
with anything either that's a important
thing no but doesn't matter let's just
launch this thing see if it works so
yarn localhost
a19 to login we'll go file online users
you can see this wonderful window pops
up and we can resize it and everything
and it's it will contain our list of
users once we add that we can close it
we can open it again and etc it will
work now one thing we should do as well
as the first time that it opens it open
to the top left corner that doesn't look
nice so we can just set the set the set
layout and I'll set layout set location
relative to null and they'll just Center
it on our window we could also pass in
the client window as a parameter here
and then set a relative to the client
window if you like but you know that's a
whole heap of things that we could do
but we're not going to just just for I
don't know just to save time I guess now
over here right what we'll do is we'll
handle the reception of a notice of
another kind of a string time right so
we've got we've got an EM kind of packet
we've got a an eye packet we've got a C
connection packet what we'll do here is
we'll actually set another one okay and
we'll call it message dot sauce with
we'll call it a u packet okay and
that'll be a users kind of packet so in
other words the server will send the
client periodically kind of like it does
with these eye pings it'll also send the
client occasionally it'll send the
client a a list of who's connected to
the server okay and this is pretty much
pacifically just for this to work right
so what we'll do what what we'll do with
that to make that work of courses we'll
have to code it in the server but
basically what will happen right is
we'll simply go ahead and go string like
an array users right we'll actually
equal our message but we'll split it
with slash you also our slash and and
you'll find out that is in a minute
and then /b to end it all right so
that's our entire right here and then
all we have to do is you could probably
imagine by now is this dot uses dot
update what I call it damn it
this one uses the update with users okay
I called it I did call it users so why
is this okay it's because it's in it's
in a new thread doesn't matter we can
just we can just call users update and
then call this you or something and
that'll work just fine over here all
right
so there you go that'll that'll be
lovely so now let's make the server send
this you packet because otherwise what
I'm carrying anything right now
so in our server we have this manage
clients where is it where I will go this
manage clients method here again and
what it does is it sends to all it sends
this pink thing
let's also send a status ok and it says
status we'll just set kind of the users
okay we'll send the users that we wants
a private void set status status status
whatever and what we'll do in there is
again we will send I guess we'll send
well well in this case we will send all
of our users that need to get sent so in
other words what we'll do is every every
single user that's connected into our
into our server here we will send a list
of that ok
now this could also be used to kind of
verify if the server still there so we
could send a status of I don't know
whatever you could do whatever you want
right so if like the servers on the
pressure of whatever you can handle
whatever you want here ok first of all
if we have no clients connected so if
client size is less than or equal to 0
so in other words it's 0 it'll never be
less than but let's just do that just in
case then let's just let's just return
ok so get out of this method otherwise
we'll be sending packets to nowhere so
first of all let's let's try tack on a
string that we'll send now so we'll make
it slightly we'll make it start with us
last year and then for each of these
clients that we've got here so eyes
lesson client starts sighs I plus plus
fresher these clients will add on their
name so users plus equals so we're
adding on to this
we're pending onto that string will add
on clients get I dot name right and then
will plus eight also will plus a slash
and slash and that's where that slash n
slash comes in that's of course because
we need to differentiate between users
okay so um because we can't just put a
bunch of names you know we've kind of
want to be able to say all right well
this is what else trends gonna look like
by the way we kind of won't want the
abilities to say something all the lines
of slash here we might have Yan
connected then the next person might be
Turner then we want to be able to
extract these names okay now at the end
we actually want to put a slash a so
what I'll do is I'll set the I equal to
a client style size minus one okay and
then I'll simply append onto the end of
this clients get clients dot size right
minus 1 of course dot dot name along
with a slash a so in other words for the
last user I won't put a slash n at the
end of him I'll put a slash a if you
only have one user available of course
it will not do this for loop at all
because we setting it to minus 1 okay
and it's a less than not less than equal
to big difference great that's pretty
much it and now we want to send to all
this string just string of users okay
that's it that's all we need to do okay
now let's go ahead and and fix this
little problem we've got here now server
because the send status thing
I'll set status send status there we go
okay this should actually work so let's
go ahead and start the server here you
can see over here in our console that
the server isn't faster started over
here in let's see where are we client
login over here in login yeah on
localhost
a-19 to login whoops we're we're in
so we'll go file online users and you
can see that it says yarn over here what
is up with this mouse
it says yarn over here now we also
get a space okay mysterious isn't it we
sometimes also get a space you can say
that we've actually got to here we've
got a space and nothing and that's a bit
of a glitch that we have which I'll talk
about in a minute
but basically we've got we've got spaces
around here which we shouldn't have so
let's go ahead and fix that quickly
we'll go ahead and go into a let's say
into our arm our client window and then
in our client window when we actually
split this you can actually see maybe
what's going on okay because of
splitting slash you and slash a it's
actually including the two users we have
at the beginning so what what it says in
it in its eyes I guess is this right and
then the next one in the array will be
on and then then the next one in the
array will be nothing it again and it's
actually putting these in the array okay
so if you were to do something like
system dot out dot print line u dot
length what you would get if we start
this quickly server is still running
again which is good if I start this
quickly and you know what whatever
misspelled my name login you can see
that uh whoops
make sure you okay see three the size is
three okay so to get rid of those things
we could just trim the trim the array
because we know that that's that that's
gonna happen in the front and be at the
end so the easiest way is gonna be to
trim the actual array now when it comes
to trimming arrays the easiest way to do
that again is just to use this little
thing that's called arrays copy from
range stuff thing so arrays dot copy of
range that's what it is and then all
we'll do here is first of all we'll put
in the array which is U and then we'll
put on the I guess the starting index
which we want it to be one right because
the first one is zero and that's a
that's the one that has no character in
it we don't want to we don't want to
have that and then finally we'll go
ahead and type in u dot length minus one
okay just like that it makes you put
another bracket in and you'll be sweet
okay that'll trim that array for us so
if we go to server main start that
address is already news I serve has
already started login we'll stop this
okay we'll go Y on localhost 8 1 9 to
log in will go file online more good
thing exit didn't work
file online users we can see yarn we can
see if yarn is the only one here every
two seconds this will get updated let's
launch another one to see if it works
I'll try and keep this up here so I'll
just hit another one really quickly
where's that other one go on let's just
you know what let's just minimize this
here it is yeah
I've started another one here I'll go
ahead and type in Cherno localhost a
one-line to login and suddenly we've got
two here we've got yarn and show no ok
if I am yarn over here that I think this
is yarn right hey you can see it
actually appears on both clients by the
way if you get rid of this then you can
see that damn we got rid of the other
one but if we go to online users it now
says China ok simple as that so
everything works as intended
ok so I hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of network Shep programming I'm
actually gonna end it there because this
is a huge episode I didn't think it
would take this long it unfortunately
did but basically everything that you
need to know about that kind of online
connection thing you know what actually
hang on to more things ok one thing I
want to do that I just forgot about
completely here cuz I'm an idiot let's
just close this first one thing that I
forgot to do in the online users jajaja
thing is is actually set a title so
let's set a title is basically just
gonna say online users ok and the other
thing I want to do is make the font a
bit bigger on that list so I'll go ahead
and go list dot set font maybe something
along the lines of new font Madonna
0:24 okay so basically 24 is the size of
the font of a downer here one thing I
also want to do is put this into a into
a scroll bar ok you'll see here in a
minute that if I was to log in with a
user that was like this ok login here
and and I was to view the online users
you can see it doesn't fit here with
that font size and I'd have to actually
make the whole window bigger why not
just add a little scroll bar let's do
that right so I'm in order to do that I
will simply go ahead and make a new J
scroll pen
I'll call P equals nu J scroll pain and
then I will simply go
paedon and set the viewport view to be
list okay and then instead of adding
this list here I'll simply add the
actual scroll pan which we called P okay
start that again
yon localhost a-19 to login file online
users oh damn it
okay let's make another one here I
didn't I didn't make my name really
longer so let's do that now okay
localhost
a19 to login alright now we should see
on the online users here
that's not even long I'll see that okay
let's make this a bit small you can see
as we make this smaller we have a scroll
pane here that we can scroll across okay
and if our online user yeah I think this
is on yarn so if we were to close the
other one you can see that and as you
can see it disappears okay brilliant so
anyway that is uh that's pretty much
gonna gonna end this episode in my
shower programming if you guys did enjoy
it please don't forget to hit the like
button there's gonna be one more I
wanted absolute that it'll be the last
one but we do have a few other server
kind of buggy admin stuff that we want
to do so um I'll definitely do that in
there in the next episode so yeah thanks
watching guys hope you enjoyed I'll see
you guys later goodbye